What is your opinion of Dr. Cbis-alcholid diet and taking Cbos and fermented
whatever plums also best way to keep my up my electrolytes?
Okay so there are alkaline diets that are out there that can be beneficial if I have
you know issue you look at your blood work to see do I have metabolic acidosis? You could equally
have metabolic alkalosis you know so it's um you want to look at your blood work to determine
that um certainly I don't know what's involved with this person's alcholid diet so I've been
not going to make a comment on it um I'm not a big fan of taking Cbos either um and I don't know
anything about these fermented plums so a best way to keep up your electrolytes is to eat a good
diet make sure you're eating your vegetables where you're going to get your minerals but let's say
you're you're sweating a lot and you're in your losing minerals or you're doing sodas or whatever
and you have low minerals based upon your blood work again then you take a good quality mineral
which should be a plant based mineral or a or a created the same way it's it's found in plants which
is double bonded to an amino acid which is the albion or the tracks minerals that are out there never
take a soil based mineral or those liquid minerals they're just a bunch of garbage you don't get your
minerals through eating dirt you get your minerals through eating plants that's the way God made it and
it's double bonded to an amino acid so that's how you should get your minerals there are electrolyte
products out there that are just fine too that are made with those types of minerals so
but just take it a good mineral is the way to get your minerals